whether plain or peanut M&Ms are one of
America's favorite movie munch apples
even in the dark they're easy to pop
into your mouth the colorful candies
have been around since 1941 first serve
to American GIs in World War two and
later to astronauts on the space shuttle
these days countless M&Ms are gobbled up
just as fast as they're made with one
woman eating her fair share I think I
managed to eat probably about a half a
pound a week in Ginny Wolf's version of
the alphabet there's only two letters
and they're both M hello some called the
M&M lady or misses M&Ms or whatever
Ginny collects anything and everything
M&M I never counted them but I would
venture to guess maybe several thousand
from M&M lunch boxes and candy
dispensers two clocks cars and hundreds
of figurines M&Ms doing everything from
skiing to skating even piloting a
hot-air balloon this mass of M's started
simply enough one Christmas with a
single stocking stuffer called a topper
there were M&Ms that came in a tube like
this and the top comes off and this was
called an ornament well I just thought
these were the cutest little things I
had seen so I saved them these toppers
are top collectibles and today Jenny's
collection includes several hundred
toppers alone each one with its own
unique personality the red is a little
bit more sarcastic yellow is just kind
of funny
crispy the orange one is paranoid he's
afraid of everybody the green girl is
the sassy little girl the blue character
is very cool
Bulova dance baby there's no doubt jenny
is the queen of eminem collectors she
reigns over an internet club of some 400
fellow Eminem maniacs
we caught the collectible to smash back
at you some of these treasured treats
are positively patriotic she's dressed
as the Statue of Liberty and she says
give me your hungry President Reagan is
credited with making MMS a US ambassador
when he took them to the former Soviet
Union for a summit these are the Ronald
Reagan boxes and his signature is on
here after that each president that came
after Ronald Reagan also had an M&M
candy box watch cooking channel for more
great episodes of unwrapped